Ukrainian forces say they're marching
further east into territory abandoned by
the Russians
now that's raising speculation they
could be planning an assault on moscow's
occupying forces in the donbass region
Ukraine says its troops are working
quickly to restore normal life in
liberated towns but despite this many
ukrainians see their Newfound Freedom as
an opportunity to flee further away from
the front lines
residents in the newly liberated town of
kupiansk getting out why they still can
with no running water or electricity
they're heading west to safer regions
deeper inside Ukrainian territory what
was an already scary situation has just
become terrifying
with heavy fighting still going on on
the city's outskirts
scared just scared
I just want to live and I'm scared for
my child
[Music]
the Russian occupation for months
movement was when they didn't let us use
the internet or contact anyone they said
it's because of people like you our
soldiers and our vehicles get targeted
verifying reports from the battlefield
is almost impossible but Ukraine's
military says it's crossed the Oscar
river which runs through kubiansk and is
now continuing its Advance East
Ukraine's President says his forces are
solidifying their control of the newly
recaptured regions
we are stabilizing the situation firmly
holding our positions so strong that the
occupiers are really panicking we warned
the Russian soldiers in Ukraine they had
only two options to flee or Surrender
meanwhile there are reports of Ukrainian
shelling further east in separatist-held
regions authorities in the
separatist-controlled city of Donetsk
say 13 people died after a Ukrainian
missile strike there
they accuse Kiev of deliberately
targeting civilians
this came as Kiev accused Moscow of
deliberately dropping missiles near a
nuclear power plant in Ukraine's
southern mikolai region
missiles fell just some 300 meters away
from the Power Station the country's
second largest
the three reactors were not damaged but
the incident has stoked fears that the
war could lead to a nuclear disaster
following the success of Ukraine's
counter-offensive in the East Russia's
Vladimir Putin has promised to step up
attacks on Ukrainian infrastructure
endangering the lives of civilians
across the country
and a correspondent Nick Connelly joins
us now from khakif Nick bring us up to
date on the fighting in Ukraine's East
just before I get that you might be
hearing Ukraine's national anthem for
the background there that's something
that is part of everyday life here every
morning at nine local time as for the
fighting well even here in you are not
totally removed from this there are lots
of Airaid uh warnings lots of uh missile
strikes pretty much every day so you
know if you're really following those
warnings you're in the cellar in your
place of safety a couple of times every
night further away from here towards
where most of those fighting that
fighting is still going on we are seeing
the ukrainians making slow but steady
progress nothing on the scale and the
speed of what happened in previous weeks
but they are pushing back Russian forces
in the northern part of donbass which is
not that far away from here because they
basically cut off the Russians from
their supply lines they've cut off their
Logistics hubs and it seems like they
are now moving the direction of civil
Nets that was a city that Russia took at
the cost of thousands of lives and a
huge amount of material um in the middle
of the summer and in kind of for the
south towards Donetsk we've seen the the
Russians trying to advance trying to
push up against positions where the
Ukraine's have been since 2014 lots of
outside observers saying it's pretty
much pointless given that these are some
of the best defended bits of the front
lines so we're seeing active fighting
but nothing of the kind of intensity and
speed that we saw prior to this okay so
the Ukrainian military has regained
ground really quite quickly in this
latest defensive it is slowing down now
but how difficult will it be to hold on
to this regained territory
well some of it is hard up against the
Russian border so in theory if the
Russians did have the resources did have
the kind of personnel to reinforce their
force their their you know groups here
they could attack just directly from
their own territory so in a sense that's
easier having said that Ukraine has
shown all along that it is very good at
defending uh that's basically what
they've been doing since the beginning
of this conflict with Russia in 2014 and
they obviously have the superior
motivation you know there's big problems
among the Russian forces among people
who basically don't know why they're
fighting don't feel any particular
connection to this campaign lots of
people who've been forced to fight
who've been Recruiters in places like
Lawrence others who've been lured in
with high salaries they're not often
actually getting paid out in full so a
sense that that isn't the bigger problem
the bigger problem is actually now going
to be just preparing for the winter and
getting you know Ukraine's Army Ready
For Fighting 30 different conditions
we know that missiles have fallen near
Ukraine's second largest nuclear
facility close to mikolai of how worried
are authorities there about what's
happened
well definitely this is very scary a
couple hundred meters only dividing that
missile strike from the main power
station this is after we've seen weeks
of tensions and of fighting around the
other big Power Station in the South
Ukraine is about Asia I think this is
about two things on the one hand this is
about upping the stakes and scaring
people in Europe who've been supporting
Ukraine that Russia is really willing to
go all out and to risk these kind of
catastrophic events to really put
pressure on European backers of Ukraine
to kind of force Ukraine back to the
negotiating table at moscow's conditions
but this is also about civilian
infrastructure people here in Ukraine
could be facing a very cold very
uncomfortable winter and if they lose
these power plants they have to be shut
down it's all going to be a lot more
difficult so far Ukraine has done a
pretty amazing job at recovering and of
kind of rebuilding stuff after damage
but if you know two huge power stations
along with all kinds of other
infrastructure are out of uh kind of out
of work out of uh normal routine
functioning then this is going to be a
situation where lots of people maybe who
want to come back to liberate spots
Ukraine won't be able to because there's
no you know normal civilian life
possible
thanks so much Nick that's Nick Connelly
reporting from hakif